the 8 news now investigators on the case
of a city councilman in Henderson being
sued for predatory payday loans across
the country these are not criminal cases
against the councilman Dan Shaw but the
allegations are enough to get the
attention of eight news now investigator
Kyle Payne
what can we do as a community to make it
affordable for our Workforce Henderson
city councilman Dan Shaw my estimation
this is probably the most critical
committee that we have right now
championing the cause of The Working Man
this community has a critical need for
Workforce housing all part of being an
elected official
along with the hand clapping
handshaking we pray that our leaders
will lean on and head bowing you might
expect from a city councilman but what
you might not expect is two Federal
class action lawsuits brought by members
of the public who say Shaw and entities
run by him and a business partner have
been preying on consumers the federal
suits basically say the same thing that
green arrow Solutions managed by Shaw
and Greg Jones charged over 700 interest
on payday loans small loans with
notoriously huge interest and Cutthroat
collection tactics all members of
council voted in favor of a motion made
by councilman Shaw the eight news now
investigators attended the most recent
Henderson city council meeting after Dan
Shaw ignored three separate requests for
an interview one by phone one by email
and one through the city spokesman but
after the meeting we found Dan Shaw
trying to avoid us but he ran right into
our camera and microphones want to know
if you had any comment on the lawsuits
or the uh
the case in Massachusetts I just have a
couple questions but Dan Shaw wasn't
answering any questions we heard from
his PR person who basically didn't
confirm or deny anything leaving us back
here in Henderson at a commercial
building where Dan Shaw used to have an
office he's not here anymore and the
property manager says he's been gone for
some time court documents back that up
and from here in Henderson the paper
trail takes us all over the map
following the trail of Shaw and Jones
payday loan businesses is difficult at
best one plaintiff is in Massachusetts
the other in Indiana Greg Jones lives in
Colorado and they have a partnership
Incorporated in Delaware other
subsidiaries in North Logan Utah and
registered agents in Reno but the trail
also takes us to California Lake County
a few hours from San Francisco to The
Big Valley band of Pomo Indians and
that's where the story gets good the
lawsuits say green arrow solutions
purports to be a tribal entity but isn't
and green arrow can skirt State interest
rate caps usually around 12 percent and
charge up to 750 interest making a 500
payday loan a seventeen hundred dollar
repayment with stiff penalties and
collection tactics all in the name of
the Pomo Indians there is no state
license just this little certificate
from the tribe hey Kyle this is Ben Ray
returning your call and
um I wanted to get back with you uh I
apologize I've been so busy I'm always
so busy tribal administrator Ben Ray not
too busy for a well-worded no comment if
you're looking to get any other contacts
which I'm sure you probably are uh you
would have to to look to Dan Shaw or
somewhere else but we here at the tribe
would not be providing any more contacts
for that story back here here to
Henderson and Dan Shaw who has a long
history of Civic service all members of
Council vote in favor of the motion made
by councilman Shaw and it carries and
litigation as a civil defendant in Clark
County's eighth Judicial District some
30 cases against him and his business
Holdings for breach of contract
non-payment of loans debts failure to
pay employees and other commercial
wrongdoing not to mention having owed
Millions to the IRS
Kyle Payne 8 News Now
of those litigations against city
councilman Shaw settled out of court in
January this one in Massachusetts may
have been settled but lawyers have about
a week longer to submit that paperwork
to the federal court there